hello all right we're back it's been a
long time hmm well compared to our days
of daily uploading that's for sure
hopefully you enjoyed the super slow
show me a lot of fun making it mm-hm and
now we're back in the back garden with
no crew and no one to help ya it's just
us we got some lovely new equipment we
do don't worry though still the same
janky old table this is the same crap
table so today we're testing out two new
cameras one very kindly provided by
Vision Research which is the Phantom
b-26 40 which in full HD do twelve and a
half thousand frames a second it's
mental hmm the the high-speed we've been
able to do in HD before is 2500 so huge
step up and also over here very kindly
loaned to us by Hasselblad is the H 6100
C which is a 100 megapixel medium format
stills camera two very different cameras
because with this one in one second I'm
going to take twelve and a half thousand
pictures and on this one I'm gonna take
one but it will be massive one weight so
you got a beefy picture and a beefy
frame rate there you can bind yeah just
beefed all around
so hopefully the idea is that we'll
revisit paint on a speaker because seems
like the perfect one to revisit with
slower speeds and you'll be able to see
the exact moment on the slow-mo that I
take this massive picture so I'm very
excited let me take up new technology
before the Sun Grace's us we've got some
work to do
yeah I've got to take this speaker like
the front bit off and use the actual
cone this is more complicated okay
just screws you'll hit there I feel like
at no point do we correctly use any of
us that works yeah they look like you're
about to axe your own crush there we go
it's a 100 watt so it should be beef
enough for the paint we'll have a base
of yellow and then the other colors will
be squirted on top
have some green buh-buh-buh-buh-buh it
looks like a weird paint pizza maybe
ready yeah
in three two one now forget how quickly
it turns to brown even though it's just
pure pain there's no water mixture in
there at all it just turns to brown
really quick
[Music]
ready yeah one by loud it in three two
one now
whoa jeez did that get on the phantom no
that does not mess about
[Music]
[Music]
oh no we look at it it's all over it
what do I do Oh Oh God I'm gonna delete
it half my stuff there summer it's messy
work this week and done with some crew
on this one I actually started to think
that so I have to set the experiment up
hold a light get the music right plug
the speaker and turn it on do that
you're operating an extremely
complicated camera and another extremely
complicated yeah
two very manual cameras yeah so the idea
behind using this camera is there I'll
be able to take a 100 megapixel image
and I'm going to set the shutter speed
to a 2000 of a second which is its
maximum hopefully they'll be enough
there might be a slight bit of motion
blur because we don't have the shutter
speed we have enough phantom and my
favorite thing about it which is
amplified by the the lens hood here is
the sound it makes when you take a
picture have a listen to this oh you can
get all the off it's like it leaves a
little ringing in your ears so I'll call
this method
stacking okay color stacking color stuck
in rainbow pancakes Oh lovely bullseye
three two one go
you
[Music]
not only is kind of great because it's
fast at high resolution it's also very
sensitive giving us the ability to shoot
12,000 frames a second for a lot of this
a team stop of eight mental and they'll
give us the depth we need we're also
using lights in that right Daniel yeah I
smoke a 64 hat
who's that yeah it's a Sun Hat what
you're in for
slo-mo really cozy round here I'm like
in the bit of shade doing my paints got
my sound my laptop so now we'll do a
sort of strip rainbow idea yeah we're
gonna lay all the different colors down
in the rainbow pattern in lines boom it
and then hopefully they'll all mix
together
so really 10 mil of each color yeah this
it's this syringe it's just really like
difficult to pull up it's like a finger
workout every time okay
all right hope this works now and I
don't mess it up that would be annoying
top is copter me to go vocal fingers
vocal fingers okay okay yeah torch is on
and in ready when you are ready okay in
three two one
now okay I'm pretty sure that look good
oh I got it really early let's take a
look at that
oh yeah how do you like that nice sweet
hope you love it
that's cool huh wow that's actually
watch this on camera shall we yeah sure
I'll be able to see your face when
watching this tonight alright look away
a bit and save it alright
oh can it rise in like that for that
that it's just king isn't that Kali all
those colors you can distinctly see them
as well I sweet I like her just for one
like sound the speaker actually moves
several times yeah it's just weird like
when you see sound of this level it's
just a bunch of vibrations which means
that some of the paint is going up and
some of it's coming back down already
and I meets in the middle look at that
it goes high as well and you can still
see the distinct colors and now it's
getting a bit more blend ear it's um
that marbling going on there was one
glob there it was falling and it had I
think I had every color in her you know
what I was bidding did you ever saved it
some good practice Lord even though that
was great and I shot on the Hasselblad
was great yeah I just want to do it
again oh so much SAP is really top down
one I'll come up on this
I almost hate finding stuff that you
love yeah I'm like oh god she's great I
just watch that forever it is really
cool it almost makes all the setup worth
it almost almost not quite quite all
that testing for this was done indoors
wasn't it yeah which means it's problems
with the wind with stuff blowing away I
see you're fakin to using your head if I
had three hands much easier but I'm just
struggling it and the thing is I could
help out but I'm just filming it yes
three two one go hopefully that was a
success it sounded like it was I heard
the click just as it was quite high oh
it's quite high but that's I like it is
it good yeah I think that's quite good
that's a class I like it that what the
torch is putting some nice sheen on the
blue mmm here is like up here when you
got that one it was higher really yeah
goodness gracious
well there's a bit yellow here that it's
just like
[Music]
so on this one I threw the focus to the
front yeah you've come really down on
the angle whoa that was a big one I
wonder what caused that yellow just come
on yeah what part of the speaker was
like just you only you look at all the
different colors mixing because it's so
hard to actually just put layers of
paint because it's a liquid it kind of
mixes already so there's paint
underneath each but other paint yeah
imagine working in a paint factory right
where his job was to mix paint but it
was just done with music now be a hell
of a place to work
you just get a beats all day long it's
part of your job oh that was cool there
when everything's settled for a moment
you can actually see the floor of the
speaker again and then he went boom take
that in doesn't that look nice lovely
looking for free top actually you think
we haven't done is that our sort of our
in slow-mo very touch to it well got an
idea actually kind of hungry we've got
some cereal and milk but I don't have a
spoon you a cereal first kind of guy or
a milk first kind of guy cereal first
boys correct answer that's enough for a
hearty breakfast I think this is gonna
be gross why cuz it's milk what's wrong
well when he gets hot and sway there's
pretty gross right okay so up until this
point because we've been using pain and
we don't want it to just completely
bugger off immediately we've actually
had the volume at like six out of ten
and I'm just gonna whack it straight up
to eleven and I haven't even seen it
eleven yet you're gonna need earplugs so
I've got earplugs in just in case it
blows my face off yeah
three two one
oh it's all over the laptop damn it
you just
it's all my beard and horrible oh I see
my eyes all right oh oh I saw love my
eyes
I'm not even funny I look and I shook
the picture and I when I went to in real
life I couldn't see your face I didn't
need to be that close I don't think did
you eat any yeah I'm out but I didn't
get any cereal only milk it's like a
milk dispenser oh yeah yeah oh oh I like
that I liked what I saw me too I
especially like the marbling and how the
colors mingled together yeah it was also
good mingling above the marbles oh I
think like the rainbow one was my
favorite
yeah me too more effort to do but
totally worth it and that was my
favorite on the house of wear too
because it was it was right I thought
I'd taken the picture too early but it
was right of the perfect moment yeah I
like that we can do these things again
but with completely new equipment I
we've got better frame rates with a
Hasselblad bigger speakers more paint
yeah I honestly revisiting our favorite
videos are the best way to test new
equipment because you get you have that
direct comparison lovely hopefully you
liked it too feel free to follow us on
Instagram and we have a second channel
and Twitter I guess oh goodness say you
know my - stinks of old milk now thanks
for that